okay so the end of The Walking Dead is
now upon us and the 12 year long journey
that began back in 2010 is officially
over chances are that a lot of you love
the shirts and point but you dropped off
along the way now back to see what
happened and whether it's worth checking
out well throughout this video we're
going to be doing a Walking Dead for
dummies breakdown that should cover
everything you need to know about the
ending Bulls spoilers ahead from here on
out so if you don't want to know what it
entrails then I highly recommend that
you turn off now click the Thumbs Up
Button if you think the breakdown is
gravy and make sure you subscribe for
videos like this every day without the
way thank you for clicking this I'm your
host Paul now let's get into The Walking
Dead
[Music]
now interestingly The Walking Dead's end
doesn't end with a Walking Dead End the
series breathes new life into things to
come and we see Rick and Michonne
setting up their own spin-off series
which is due to start filming next month
at the ending sort of acts as a trailer
for that where they're teasing what's to
come I'll talk about this more in a bit
but we start off with Daryl carrying
Judith into a hospital sort of in a Last
of Us Style with Joel and Ellie the
first episode of The Walking Dead of
course had a major moment where Rick
woke up in one and the series is sort of
coming full circle from that the
characters are either there or desperate
to get there and returning to a location
like this is sort of like poetry they
rhyme in case you're not fully up to
speed with where the Commonwealth is
this is basically a recreation of life
before the outbreak they had all the
characters saying we live in a society
run by corrupt politicians led by Pamela
Milton the entire season's built towards
an uprising and she ended up unleashing
a zombie horde which put the citizens
into lockdown no prizes for guessing
what that's a reference to add it
through everything into chaos this
episode very much becomes about taking
her down and freeing the citizens of the
Commonwealth to start something better
after we see the title sequence for the
last time we cut to the Carnage
happening in the Commonwealth and see
both Luke and Jules being attacked by
the undead she's eaten alive while she's
taking the hospital and unfortunately
he's been bitten as well a classic
Walking Dead style the character had a
limb amputated but unfortunately this
was too little too late and he goes out
as quickly as he came back now Daryl
ends up giving Judah the blood
transfusion due to him being a universal
donor turns out his brother merlax used
to sell his blood for money when they
were little and yeah looking back very
messed up now luckily the transfusion
works and Judith wakes up a couple of
scenes later having pulled through
Judith very much foreshadows the return
of Rick and Michonne as she brings up
how she and the pair were meant to be
reunited again this is clearly setting
up one of the major arcs that will
happen in their series and now they've
got some villains to fight I think it
will likely center around them having to
find their daughter well well Lori's
daughter because she's not Michonne's
and Shane was the biological dad so
reunited with some Chumps basically see
a chump now but Kelly Fleming who plays
her has always said that Rick is very
much a true father because he's the
person who raised her in the world of
The Walking Dead the characters
unfortunately are gonna see several
people die and thus they end up forming
their own families out of who is Left
Behind very much echoed in Rosita later
and I like the way that it's sort of
touched upon here foreshadowing what's
to come the previous episode of the
finale was even called family and it's
very much using the fast and furious
definition we also get this ass kicker
exchange hey the last kicker
hey big ass kicker now this is a
reference back at the scene which
unfortunately is potato quality because
we we couldn't find a better version but
pretend it's an HD the last kicker the
last kicker you like that huh now we got
back at the Commonwealth and watch
Mercer being rescued and this sets up
things for Negan Maggie and cow to Mana
permission to the hospital Aaron and
Lydia arrive camouflaged in the Walkers
with the ladder having her arm amputated
due to being bit last week elsewhere
Rosita Gabriel in Eugene managed to save
Coco and the kids and that Walker trying
to reach it in the crib was pretty
horrifying however upon trying to escape
their ambulances swarmed by the undead
and maybe they could have seen that
happening if they'd ride their
horoscopes horoscopes
the hospital is being swarmed too well
they're seeing more this mod zombies
Casey just checking in to find out what
happened in the finale because you need
closure then basically the undead have
started evolving eating all those brains
must have helped out and as I run out of
some that are able to climb and also use
tools some have the awareness to pick up
weapons and blunt objects which we see
demonstrated here using a rock a walker
is able to smash a window in the
hospital entrance and thus they can
flood the building I kinda wish that
they'd introduce these elevated aspects
in earlier Seasons as we did hit a point
where where the undead were just Cannon
for her this makes them feel infinitely
more dangerous as we had just hit a
point where people were slicing through
them without any danger we sort of get
that demonstrated in the scene with
Rosita as she falls off a pipe gets
swarmed and then still seemingly comes
out on top jumping on top of the
ambulance oh sat there like here we go
again and we see she moves up the pipe
you just fell from getting back to
safety or so we think Rosita later
reveals to Eugene that she was actually
bitten during this moment but that she
didn't want anyone to know it's such a
heartbreaking moment and I'll actually
watch this scene twice now and knowing
the reveal it hits even harder it
initially just starts off in silence and
she just sits there staring at CoCo
trying to take everything in Eugene
brings up teaching her to swim at
Oceanside and knowing this won't happen
is completely devastating Eugene's gonna
be the one who's taking care of Coco now
and it ties back to this idea of family
and how those Left Behind are the ones
who raise the others just feels like she
was robbed and sat there Imagining the
life she should have had now this scene
is murdered in the one that precedes it
with Maggie and Negan here he apologizes
flat out to her and says he's sorry for
taking Glenn away from her and their son
negan's starting his own family now and
he knows what he took from the pair in
his power play to intimidate them in the
last episode he was almost executed
along with Annie and it was very much a
role reversal for him making him realize
how Maggie and Glenn would have felt
negan's gone on one of the most
interesting arcs in the entire series
and seen the regret on his face speaks
volumes and he vows to kill Pamela for
her from here we get a very reflective
scene which acts very much as the Calm
before the storm Daryl Carol and Judah
did have a major scene in which he asks
about what she said about her parents
during her delirium she apologizes for
not telling them about what Michonne
said but the pieces quickly broken when
we see survivors trying to climb the
gates of the Commonwealth pandler is
ordering for them to be shot by the gods
and this causes those inside a mount up
they storm the Troopers guns drawn and
slowly convinced the forces that the way
Pamela operates is wrong they were so
stuck trying to make the world how it
used to be that in the end they forgot
all the problems that came with it
people are cowardly selfish and they've
forgotten that Humanity has one enemy
which are the Walkers Daryl says not one
enemy we need The Walking Dead which is
a bit on the nose but it shows how they
have to keep their Humanity instead of
just mindlessly centering on their own
wants and needs Above All Else Maggie
spots Pamela getting arrested and Negan
tells her that for a person like her
it's actually worse than death now this
is very much Negan talking about himself
as well Rick allowed him to live and
that was actually a greater punishment
than if he'd killed him because of the
guilt that he had to confront now they
let the people outside in as a horde
closes around them and Pamela walks up
to the gate here stands a reanimated
lance and Pamela would genuinely rather
have a face bitten off by him than going
to jail so man she looked down on for
years and he's very much a reflection of
the evil Deeds that she's carried out he
represents the people and this
metaphorically symbolizes an uprising
against crooked politicians at least
that's how I took it anyway now her
attempting to get eaten by him shows
that she'd rather have her head torn
apart than actually having to face up to
what she's done which is a bit mental
Maggie instead shoots him and Julia
convinces her that it's not too late to
help people we've of course seen that
happen with Negan and she changes her
mind but there's still a [ __ ] to deal
with Mercer brings in a new plan which
involves the citizens mounting her with
ride Shields and they heard the Walkers
using a song called The Cult of
Personality this is by the band Living
Color and it has a lot of meaning to it
now the phrase the cult of personality
he was actually coined in the 50s in an
anti-starland report the song was meant
to explore what good and bad figures
have in common and how people tend to
follow those whose personalities they
gravitate towards some people are larger
than life but at the end of the day
everyone is just human however their
personalities make them seem bigger and
people can become Idols based on who
they are and the amount of people that
follow them the followers of politicians
are often said to have been swayed and
that they're in the cult of personality
so having the Walkers follow this song
to me at least is a nod to that Pamela
was of course a political figure and
many of the people surrounding her fell
into the cult of personality this scene
following after her downfall and having
them all go up with the estate
metaphorically shows how the brain dead
zombies have finally seen Shu the cult
that she's created might be a big reach
like I said but there are things you can
apply to real life here and how
following someone blindly can often lead
to your downfall anyway this leads to a
gigantic explosion that's e you see the
best in the show's history it wipes out
the entire estate along with the Walkers
and is the final goodbye to this corrupt
leadership and everything that it stood
for in jail Pamela talks about how heavy
lies the crown and how leadership comes
with the necessity to make ugly
decisions outside Negan throws away the
whisper mask which symbolizes the
closing of that chapter even though it
was a while ago and he and Maggie sit
together Maggie says she'll never be
able to fully forgive Negan for smashing
Glenn's head like it's the like button
but she remains grateful that he saved
her son and that he's out here trying
she knows she doesn't want to hurt
anymore so she will try too because she
doesn't want anyone to have that kind of
hold over here I bet she knows it will
be difficult because she remembers Glenn
dying every time she looks at Negan she
doesn't want that to dominate her life
and says that Negan and Annie have
earned their place now however she
apologizes for being unable to look at
him some days due to the pain it will
bring up and yeah it's a very
Bittersweet scene Adara watches him
leave and as he later sends the compass
back I don't think they're going to be
around all that much however they have
to be close for that to happen so
they're likely residing at Hilltop now
this scene also sets up their show The
Walking Dead dead City a brand new
trailer for this has just dropped and we
know from it that it will be set in New
York though we don't have a general
outline of it yet it's likely going to
be about forgiveness and Maggie learning
to look at him without seeing her
husband being murdered I've also seen
the start of Batman v Superman and maybe
maybe let's hope these two can make
something just to also get murdered in
front of the one they love they have a
last supper and if you cast your mind
back to season seven there was a dream
scene in which a picnic played out we
even saw Glenn there and it was very
much a what if version of the future
that would never come to be it's a very
similar thing that happens here and it
all plays out as a happy and peaceful
time the song Landslide by Fleetwood Mac
plays over the top and we see several
things playing out Magna kisses yumiko
they make up and we see rosito also
telling Gabriel Rosita is just enjoying
the time she has left and psychic Judith
can also sense something is up everyone
must slowly have become aware as we see
her getting carried up to be with her
daughter where Gabriel reads her her
last rights he takes Coco and says that
they'll see her again someday Eugene
comes in and the pair have of course had
their highs and lows throughout the
entire series mama was basically like
Forrest Gump holding on for his Jenny
and in the end she says
I'm glad it was you in the end
must have been some dust in the room uh
cause his final scene broke me a bit and
made me do full-on Kevin Smith it shows
the bond that the pair had and out of
everyone in the end she'd rather it was
him by her side and from here we get a
one-year time Jump and see how things
have moved on there are still memories
of those that have died but Eugene has
had his own child who's now named Rosie
after
now Ezekiel is now the governor with
Lieutenant these videos are really
bottom so now Ezekiel is now the
governor with Lieutenant Mercer as his
right hand man Carol is also taking up a
new position and he's been appointed as
the new improved Lance Negan is sent due
to the present through Lydia and we see
that this is the compass that she let
him use this shows that he no longer
needs it because he's not searching for
anything or looking in another direction
from where he is he hopes that it will
help guide her to her dreams and this
once more resembles the picnic scene
from season 7 showing how everything has
worked out here they built a community
in future and Maggie says that they
should Branch out more Carol and Daryl
did have their own spin-off show in the
works but we now know that Melissa
McBride pulled out and this this ending
with the pair is very much them saying
their goodbyes they say it's not like
they'll never see each other again but
we'll see what happens when contracts
are brought into it Daryl heads up on
the road and it is possible that he
might bump into Rick and Michonne he
says that if he sees is anything out
there he'll find them and Daryl popping
up in their show would be a big thing to
get viewers back Judith promises to look
after Doug and Carol for him and the
pairs say that they love each other best
mates and they deserve that happy ending
now he is getting his own show too and
that could possibly take him to France
this is where the virus originated and
it would make sense as to why this
goodbye was so heartbreaking because he
probably won't come back he heads out on
the road and no Walkers still run the
landscape there is the feeling of
security to it and that everyone's gonna
be all right whether it's not over and a
match Sparks up to reveal Michonne and
Rick both writing letters to Judith Rick
says he thinks about the Dead all the
time which Michonne also Echoes beyond
that we also get flashes of basically
all the characters in the show in the
sort of Days of Our Lives Montage it's
very spiritual talking about how their
souls all kind of wine together and the
pair sort of have a Teenage Mutant
Turtles can't buy a seed you know when
they reached out to Splinter psychically
sort of like that now a helicopter
arrives and it becomes clear that Rick
has escaped the CRM this stands for
civic Republic military and the
antagonists that have appeared in pretty
much every spin-off show ranging from
Fear The Walking Dead to the world
Beyond on The Walking Dead well beyond
Jada said that she traded Rick to them
for admittance into the Civil Republic
which is located in Philadelphia made
above 200 000 survivors Rick was taken
there and due to the stickies carrying
we know that he was part of a
decontamination Center a comicbook.com
did a big interview with a showrunner to
talk about what's going on in the scene
and they said that Judo is hard work he
was promoted to being a soldier when
discussing the scene with the site the
director said in this particular moment
in time they're thinking about each
other they're thinking about the people
that they love and the people that
they've lost and to do that and to know
that the reason that they are still
dedicated to their fight is because of
the people that they lost and the people
that they love so that's what it was all
about and without a doubt I feel like we
captured that Spirit and the spirit of
moving forward what the world has store
for them this series presents an epic
love story of two characters changed by
a changed World kept apart by Distance
by an Unstoppable Power by the ghosts of
who they were Rick and Michonne are
thrown into another world built on a war
against the dead and ultimately a war
against the living can they find each
other and who they were in a place in
situation unlike anything they've ever
known before are they enemies lovers
victims Victors without each other are
they even alive or will they find that
they too are The Walking Dead
I think that the upcoming series will
explore Rick's time with them and along
with him as shown he'll take them out
possibly with some help from Daryl he'll
then tell them about Judith and this
will bring everything full circle now
Michonne is also wearing a samurai-esque
suit which likely comes from the group
that we saw in her last episode before
this it's also important to bear in mind
that the boat we see is also boat 672
which has appeared earlier in the series
this came after Michonne recognized
bricks boots and she realized that he
was out there so lots of things going on
and huge shout outs to movie Idol for
saying that Beale could be involved in a
scene too we just don't see him Michonne
rides towards a giant horde ready to
take them on and Rick starts to smile as
we Fade to White you also get a little
Coda with Judith which kind of teases
that they will be reunited again now the
little smile from Rick to me at least
says like you guys don't know what
you're messing with come on and bring it
that's on it's so British I said come on
come on and bring it you you chump uh
but yeah that that's a feeling I get and
he's clearly not intimidated showing
he's ready for whatever they may bring
either way that wraps up the season and
you know what after all its ups and
downs I thought this was a pretty good
way to close things off but yes now I've
wondered how they're actually gonna end
this whole thing and it would be
impossible to do it and completely
knocking out the park I thought this was
as satisfying as a send-off that we ever
could have got had some action to it a
heartbreaking death I'm still I'm still
not over and also some hope for the
future sure the gang have been through
this a number of times where they set up
shop and then it all comes crashing down
but this feels different it gave me
enough to want to check out the Rick and
Michonne series which I think is as good
as it can get in terms of being a season
finale that sets up some spin-offs it's
while looking back at The Walking Dead
and thinking about how much you
popularized zombies back before they
became the guru thing this was the show
that resurrected them and though it's
had its bad in good times I think we'll
probably look back on it fondly it had
thousands of copies just like how
screenran take your entire thumbnail
style and try to pass it off as theirs
but this is still the original whether
it's the best is up or debate but yeah I
did think this was a satisfying
conclusion to a story that I didn't ever
think would get one in the end we were
The Walking Dead oh no we weren't The
Walking Dead and that's our breakdown
that's that's the ending I explained
obviously I'd love to hear your thoughts
on it so make sure you comment below
we're in a competition right now giving
away three copies of House of the
Dragons season 1 on the 15th of December
and all you have to do to be when the
chance of winning is like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the finale if you pick the
comments at random on the 15th and the
winners of the last one are on the
screen right now so that's you message
me on Twitter at heavy spoilers you want
some mellitus to watch then make sure
you check out our Brighton of 1899 which
will be linked on screen right now great
series lots to take from the ending so
definitely head over there right after
this by the way thanks for singing
through the video I've been poor I'll
see you next time take care peace